so some of you know I like to blog and
so I need a photo for the trip report
that I'm gonna write about my visit here
today so if you don't wanna be in this
photo just cover your face otherwise
smile selfie time alright thanks okay so
I'm gonna talk today about learning to
code and I think that as Michael said
this is this is a some of the stuff that
I do but it's some of the stuff that I
think is most important today in a lot
of the things happening in the world so
I want to give give my attention to this
topic and try to give you a sense of how
I'm thinking about learning to code in
society today and how people in the
world are thinking about it too and some
of the tensions between my perspectives
and and others so a bit about myself to
to go deeper I've been a professor at
the University of Washington in Seattle
for about 10 years now tenured and I did
my PhD at Carnegie Mellon at the HCI
Institute and for context I was part of
the third cohort there and so figuring
out what a PhD 8th and HCI even meant at
the time was still a nun undetermined
question and so it was a lot of fun to
be part of that formative first couple
of classes at CMU and then I have a very
interdisciplinary background I studied
computer science and psychology as an
undergraduate I took a lot of design
courses when I was a PhD student and
I've continued to try to pick up new
disciplines and new backgrounds and if
lately been reading a lot about learning
science as part of that and so I tend to
think of myself as somebody who really
is a breath wise scholar and not not
necessarily going deep into a discipline
but I do that from the perspective of
thinking about what code is so here's
the perspective that I start with in my
work I think as an HCI researcher of
code as the most powerful interface that
we've ever invented but it's also the
least usable interface that we've ever
invented
it's the hardest thing to use to create
to express right it's a lot easier to go
open up some Adobe product and do some
graphic design than it is to go write
some software to do what you want and I
kind of sort of think from a justice
perspective that everybody that wants to
be able to harness this power should be
able to harness it it's something that
we should allow people to do by lowering
barriers whenever possible but there
really are immense barriers to doing
this and so when I was a PhD student and
for the
Civil years of my faculty career I spent
a lot of time trying to lower these
barriers by creating new developer tools
and other kinds of technologies that
would make it easier to express easier
to debug easier to test verify all of
these activities and I thought that that
was sort of the most powerful way for me
to spend my time was creating
technologies that would would lower
barriers what happened was I took a
small leave and started a company and
ended up actually engineering and and
managing a lot of Engineers and I
realized something that was sort of
evident every day and that's that skills
are just more powerful than tools what
human beings can do and what kinds of
insights they have about how to solve
problems there are the things that drive
our use of tools it's not the other way
around right so the kinds of things I
saw tools were amplifying people's
abilities if they knew what they were
doing they could harness tools to do
amazing things if my engineers had no
idea what they were doing tools just
derailed them they ended up somewhere
that was unproductive
and if we want people to have skills
skills come from learning learning comes
from teaching and as a result as a
manager of engineers I spend most of my
time teaching skills that was my primary
job as a chief technology officer and
that was a really pivotal ID idea for me
I mean sort of rethinking my own
scholarship because it meant that tools
were not really the objective or the
powerful agent of change in the work
that I was doing but rather skills and
and all of the problem-solving behind it
that's what I actually needed to develop
if I wanted to lower barriers to
harnessing that power of code so at the
exact same time that I was having this
realization the world also decided that
this was a skill everybody should have
right so all of the things that happen
on the left and are happening now code
org for example reaching its 500 million
learner milestone for the types of
learning that happens in hour of code
the President or former presidents
saying everybody should learn this or
everybody that once too should learn
this these are really powerful societal
changes and they're not just in the
United States they're all over the world
and then most recently on the right we
have a fairly significant investment by
industry saying this is something that
we want people to have access to as well
so while I was realizing that this was
important to me as a scholar
the world was deciding this was
important sort of economically and from
a justice perspective and so this was
really the right time for me to to make
that pivot and think about these
problems and so the first question that
I asked myself was is any of this
working what do we know about whether
learning is happening and we have some
evidence not great so feel free to pick
it apart as much as you want but this is
this is the sort of converging ideas
that we have around the evidence here's
some evidence from code.org itself about
77% of the people who've done
interactions with its code studio
environment complete somewhere on the
order of zero to two puzzles and these
are very very simple puzzles so if
learning is happening not much is
happening right there's not a lot of
engagement here and not a lot of
activity if you look at AP Computer
Science in high schools in the United
States there's record enrollment in AP
CS and its companion ApS principles but
most don't take the exam and about 60%
of who who do fail the exam meaning they
get a score of a1 or a2 and the failure
rates are even higher for
underrepresented minorities so there's
some more data that whatever we're doing
in these high school classes kind of
isn't working and the failure rates are
much lower than other AP subjects so
that's high school if we look at college
which is where a lot of the research has
been and I'll talk about that shortly
most undergrads if you really go to
systematically measure what students
after a year of CS courses can do they
can't do much they can't predict the
outcome of a simple program they can't
really solve simple programming problems
the knowledge they have is very very
brittle and the reason that we often
don't notice this is because we only pay
attention to the students that finish
right there's all of this dropout an
attrition there's the students that get
an A in the class but because our
assessments aren't very valid or robust
we don't see that they're failing or
that their knowledge is brittle so
there's this sort of hidden masked
problem in the undergraduate setting
that we don't often think about or talk
about and then finally when you look at
coding boot camps for sure there's new
phenomena from the past few years there
were 23,000 adults last year that
enrolled in these about a quarter of
those reported their dropout rates and
the dropout rates range from 10 to 50
percent and
most of them are on the higher end and
so when you look at a lot of the
experiences that students are having
here they're finding that they don't
believe they can learn this material
they're not getting feedback that they
can so they leave so these are all of
the settings in which this learning is
happening most of them were seeing the
same things it's hard material to learn
and teachers don't really know how to
teach it the last stat here that's sort
of the most concerning is that there
have been some recent surveys around how
software companies think about the
skills that graduates have and about
two-thirds of them say that entry-level
developers they'll hire them you know
because they can't they don't have any
other options but they generally don't
have the basic programming knowledge
that they need to be productive in a
company and not even just from a sort of
soft skills software engineering
perspective but even just basic
understandings of how programming
languages work how software is
architected and so on there's a gap
there so I did some more reading on why
all of this failure might be happening I
read all of the seminal literature and
learning science and education and I
read 30 years of computing education
research to try to understand what these
papers have to say about this and these
are some of the venues where that's
published and if you distill it all down
I think most people in the field that
publish this would agree that there are
six problems here probably more but the
six major ones one people really do find
computing very boring very solitary and
very unwelcoming in most of the settings
in which it's taught to people struggle
to learn their first programming
language and if they don't get past that
they don't really move any further past
that people struggle to solve
programming problems they don't have a
process for solving problems and nobody
really teaches the process teachers
struggle to teach these things and
perhaps the most surprising is that
number five most teachers one day
struggle to teach them they don't blame
themselves they blame learners they say
that learners must be broken in some way
there must be some people that know how
to code and some people that don't so
let's just focus on the ones that are
succeeding and then finally because of
all of these things most learners lose
confidence and give up and this happens
over and over again in all of these
different settings in which people are
trying to learn and these are big nasty
gnarly problems they happen probably on
this campus they certainly happen on
our campus at the University of
Washington they happen in the 25 coding
boot camps all around the Puget Sound
that we've that we've looked at and now
they're gonna happen in high schools
middle schools and K through K through
five settings right so this is not just
a problem of higher ed anymore it's a
problem in this country for all forms of
education and in the rest of the world
so in reducing this down and trying to
focus some of my goals have been trying
to look at these problems of learning
programming languages and programming
process I think there are challenging
things are in the socio-cultural aspects
of learning that that I'm not well
equipped to answer and I think that we
have a lot of great people in the field
that are tackling those I wanted to
focus on the ones that I had expertise
on and that really was the learning of
this content so I want to talk about
that and the rest of this talk and try
to figure out why are they hard and what
are some effective and equitable and
scalable ways for people to learn these
skills that move me on some of the ways
that we do this is teaching and learning
now so I'll talk about why learning is
hard and give some instances of studies
we've done recently that kind of
uncovers some some facts about this I'll
talk about how to make programmers
programs easier to read and how to make
programs easier to write and share some
new theories that we have and some
studies that kind of test and validate
them okay so why is learning programming
under the program I'm so difficult I've
done a lot of ways to look at this
problem one of them is just by engaging
deeply with people who are learning this
is a group of of students that I taught
a couple of summers ago through our
Upward Bound program at the University
of Washington so these are all
first-generation college students who
had some curiosity about about
programming and learning to code and I
just engage with them deeply and and
mentored a lot of them and over the past
couple of summers worked with about 70
of them most of them in Seattle are
refugees from other countries that have
just arrived in Seattle and some of them
are our locals but most of them are
refugees and some of the things that we
found this is just highlights many teens
locked feedback or support about their
learning from teachers or from anybody
else so here's a quote he doesn't spend
much time with me to be able to
understand my problem in the class or
help me on it throughout the AP class
I'd cry myself to sleep in silence
without letting my older brother know my
sister
all right so this brother was the one
that encouraged him to take the class in
the first place and then he provided no
support so that's an experience right
some teens actually had productive
informal mentoring relationships they
these mentors provided encouragement and
instruction and guidance and feedback
and all of that was associated with
higher interest in learning to code and
this was independent of gender or
socioeconomic status so there was this
really interesting relationship between
just having one person that encouraged
your learning to keep somebody engaged
over time and they really sought
teachers and mentors who wouldn't judge
them for their failures who would
inspire them to learn who had the
expertise to actually guide them towards
developing new skills and these are
really sort of common things amongst
most kinds of learning and education I
think we often just forget them when we
talk about computing another setting
that we've looked at is boot camps and
so one of my students Kyle fair did an
interview study with recent graduates or
dropouts of 26 different coding boot
camps in the Puget Sound region and he
found a couple of interesting things
about their experiences their son son
boot camps were very inclusive and
encouraging very intentionally so but
others were not and they offered no
instruction or feedback so here's a
quote so they're trying to get you into
this mentality if you have to read all
the documentation they sit in the
background so let students read it and
what annoys me is that I paid a lot of
money so that somebody could teach it to
me they weren't here to just read API
Docs right they were here to help
somebody instruct them through other
boot camps offered some unwelcoming
culture that we might all be familiar
with in other settings especially for
learners without prior knowledge here's
a quote it was divided the class those
with experience I think they were
looking down at those of us without
experience because maybe there were
certain things we were supposed to know
that we didn't right so these are other
socio-cultural factors and kind of
shaping whether somebody felt included
and encouraged we've also looked at
things less empirically and more
analytically we took a look at 30 coding
tutorials and this is a student I've
worked with a doctoral student who
didn't know how to code but wanted to
learn
so we had her go and use the 30 most
popular coding tutorials on the web to
see how much she could learn and then
analyze it from a learning perspective
so we kind of looked at for learning
science principles these tutorials
should connect instruction to prior
knowledge organize declarative knowledge
direct facts about programming languages
and other things offer personalized
feedback on practice and foster some
self regulated learning in the
problem-solving that it was asking
people to do while they were writing
code so the student ADA she completed
all of these tutorials analyzed every
element of her experience against all
four of these and found that most of
these tutorials don't do any of these
things right and not surprisingly the
small number of studies that we've
looked at for the learning outcomes of
these tutorials show that most mostly no
learning happens you can get this great
experience of having been exposed to
coding but mostly people can't do
anything after they've finished this so
synthesizing this why is it so difficult
few of these contexts actually teach
programming there are many opportunities
to read and write code in all of these
settings right you get exposed to it you
encounter it but learners really receive
very little feedback on whether they're
reading it correctly or they're writing
it correctly it's almost as if we expect
learners just by exposure to be able to
infer everything they need to know about
how to write programs and and it
shouldn't be surprising that since they
received no instruction on it that they
don't you don't actually make that
inference so the first half of things I
want to present around interventions for
this is about reading and I want to talk
about what reading code is about and try
to theorize about that and talk about
some of our efforts to teach it and then
we'll do writing and then I'll wrap up
so here's why most people think
understanding programs is hard and these
are sort of the fears that have existed
for several decades a lot of people
think that we just have the wrong
programming language if we redesign
languages then reading will be easier
and that's the solution to all of our
problems others have talked about having
the wrong environment the wrong tools if
we redesign those maybe everything will
be easier to scarily some people still
believe in biology and biological
explanation
they believe that there's some people
that have a geek gene that allows them
to read code effectively and other
people don't have that gene and we just
have to decide who has that gene by
making really hard midterms and final
exams and we'll figure it out
right there's no evidence for any of
these theories so I'm not saying they're
wrong but we certainly don't know that
they're right and so really where I'm
starting from is saying that the
theories that we're just teaching it
wrong right that's what's made these
things hard we need to find better ways
of explaining how to read programs and
so here's a definition that I'll propose
sort of theoretically I'll claim that
knowing a programming language means two
things being able to reliably and
accurately predict some arbitrary
program's operational semantics what
will it do
what will the program do without the aid
of some other environment to actually
execute the program
that's what knowing how to read a
program means and then secondarily you
have to know how all of those semantics
map onto syntax right because that's the
notation that we use for expressing
semantics it's a pretty basic definition
of that knowledge but it's tied to
programming languages in a way that
really other theories haven't been and
note that I'm sort of ignoring all of
the other things like design patterns
and architectures and tools there's a
lot of other stuff you have to know to
write programs I'm just talking about
reading them right now so here's an
example of what it means to know an if
statement in JavaScript you have to know
that first this condition is evaluated
second if it's true then the things in
the first pair of curly braces happen
and if it's not true then the second
thing happens and there's this other
critical knowledge that if the else
branch is true cuz the expression is
false then the then branch doesn't
execute which is a thing that a lot of
beginners don't understand they think
that it's just going to be sequential
because that's how well other reading
works right so understanding those
semantics is really key knowing a whole
language like all of JavaScript means
knowing all of the semantics so in
JavaScript for example there's about 90
ish non terminals in the grammar that
map onto all of these semantic nuances
knowing the whole semantics of
JavaScript means understanding all of
those non terminals and their semantics
and yet most intra program
classes most tutorials most coding boot
camps and never teach any of these
things
in fact I looked at our recent version
of our CS one course at u-dub the first
homework assignment is to write a Java
program that has function declarations
function calls string literal string
concatenation and a semantics of all of
those things are never taught somehow
students are just supposed to magically
infer how all of those things work right
through the process of writing a program
we've looked at lots of ways in the
community of teaching these things I
think it should be obvious that teaching
people's semantics through formal
notations like this probably doesn't
work right it doesn't teach syntax it
requires learning another notation to
learn a notation explaining semantics
via natural language doesn't work so
well because that's ambiguous and
there's a weak mapping to syntax you can
have people write programs and hope that
they will somehow infer semantics
through a process of debugging that
doesn't work so well nobody ever infers
the semantics you might even have people
step through a program's execution the
challenge there is that this is always
at the granularity of a line of code you
have to somehow be able to see
everything that happens inside of a
complex expression all at once right and
again people will not will not infer
semantics at that level of granularity
so how should we teach semantics that's
the big question here and the approach
that I'm that I'm gonna take here is
teaching a notional machine some
representation of how the program
operates and executes and so we'll show
each step of the semantics and the
explicit effects of that part of the
program on State on a program counter on
a call stack on memory and then map all
of the semantics in those side effects
to syntax so that learners create an
association between the syntax they're
seeing in the notation and the side
effects that that program is having and
its behavior so there's three ways that
we've tried doing this I'm gonna give
you a tour through them just so you can
see different ways that this basic
pedagogy manifests the first one is
Gidget and here the idea is take this
cute little robot that has been dented
and is broken who cannot debug its
programs and it needs your help and
frame coding as a collaboration between
the learner and this robot and give
learner a sequence of debugging puzzles
in which they
counter the semantics of the programming
language by seeing a broken program and
seeing how those semantics play out in
its behavior and then the goal is to
guide learners attention towards
contextualized instruction about the
programming languages semantics so that
they can map those on to syntax and
build that knowledge so here's here's
how it plays out there's a splash screen
and they get to learn a little bit about
the environment and see the story behind
Gidget being broken and not being able
to solve its problems and then there's a
variety of panels here around the code
on the left and the runtime state on the
right and then there's a test case in
the bottom left that verifies whether
the puzzles been solved by just having a
certain output and state be possible and
then all of this instruction happens
down here and get its thought bubble and
so over the course of 37 levels in this
game it teaches the 12 major semantics
of the programming language and includes
lots of formative assessments to verify
that somebody understands them so that's
the overarching curriculum so we'll jump
ahead to level 20 this is where they
learn functions and function calls and
here what happens is we have a lot of
embedded instruction so there's
explanations about what functions are
what they're used for
why they're valuable so there's a bit of
semantics explanation there digit here
is explaining the syntax and how that
maps on to the semantics through this
instruction as they execute the program
step by step it's like running through
with a breakpoint debugger but at the
token level instead of the line level
and seeing every single one of those
pieces of side-effect from the program
executing and that green line underlines
the part of the semantics that's being
explained so gadgets job as they step
through it is to say what happened as a
result of that part of the program
executing building up that association
between syntax and semantics and then in
this case we're trying to expose them to
function calls and how to call functions
and so Gidget points out where the
functions are sort of listed this is
like an API documentation right here and
this gate has this open gate function
that the program is trying to call you
might already notice on the top there
that it's calling open fence instead of
open gate so it's a pretty simple defect
in the program
we just want a guide to learn his
attention to that and so the learners
going to step through and see that it
couldn't find a function called open
fence and then they supposed to see this
association that is called open gate and
once they've recognized that there's
this notion of name resolution that the
names have to match for the functions to
be called then they can go repair that
defect step through their program and
see it work correctly so the general
theme here is that learners are
encountering semantics right it's
actually not as aggressive as maybe our
theory would recommend it's just showing
the semantics to them and hoping that
they understand this Association but
what you found is that actually works
reasonably well there we did for online
controlled experiments about a thousand
adult learners across all of these
studies we found that learning is twice
as fast as in the code Academy tutorial
for python and it's about twice as much
for open-ended creative exploration
there are levels that involve
assessments where we're asking learners
to predict the output of programs and
including those assessments increases
learning efficiency by about double
we also found interesting design factors
like how do we get learners to pay
attention to that instruction to engage
its thought-bubble it turns out by just
giving the robot eyes and having it use
personal pronouns like I and you and we
try to try to establish that
collaborative relationship we redirected
their attention towards that instruction
rather than to other parts of the
interface and so trying to do that in an
online environment was key I mean all of
this has really rapid effects on
attitudes as well when you have adults
for example play this for 20 minutes
they their opinions about whether
learning to code is easy shift from
being it's the hardest thing I could
never learn it - that was fun give me
more right how do I learn more so it's a
very rapid shift in attitude this has
had some impact so 20,000 people have
played the game so far this directly
informed the design of code or code
studio and a lot of the ways that they
provide instruction and it also directly
informed the design of Apple's Swift
playgrounds which is a similar
environment for learning the Swift
programming language the second strategy
was much more explicit rather than
trying to let learners encounter the
semantics of a programming language this
strategy is around explicitly teaching
those semantics and guiding somebody
through that mapping of syntax to
semantics so here the idea was create
this an interactive textbook where
learners walk through step by step the
program's execution and along the way we
explain what's happening each step and
then ask learners to predict for certain
parts of the program what will happen
next and the idea here is to sort of use
a causal inference model where somebody
sees this mapping between this syntax
executing with this side-effect and then
be able to build up that knowledge by
having somebody predict what that
side-effect would be so I'll show you an
example of that and we did this for
JavaScript so this is the entire
JavaScript semantics each chapter covers
some of the semantics in JavaScript and
it takes about three hours to go through
this and so the goal here is teach
JavaScript in three hours and have that
knowledge be more robust than something
you might learn in a 10-week course or a
15-week course so it's basically divided
into three sections there's a lesson on
the left that explains why in the world
would you want to understand this part
of the programming language at all what
is it for the middle shows the program
and its syntax and that links syntax to
semantics and then the right on-state
shows the program's runtime state but
also explains the side effects of each
instruction on that state so here's how
it plays out here's an if statement it's
describing what if statements are for
and giving some example of the syntax
and then saying that we're gonna step
through an if statement and see how it
executes this next button is moving
through an execution trace of this
program history right so you can see on
the top those little bubbles popping up
and down that's each individual step of
this program's execution recorded and
and captures so that we can actually
insert instruction into certain parts of
the programs execution history and then
as they step through it the state is
saying things like this is an if
statement it's used to perform some
steps conditionally the first step of in
this statement is to evaluate its
condition to see whether the step should
be performed and so they're reading and
side effects as they go along through
this program's execution
and then they can also go reverse
because we have a trace of the program's
execution history so if they miss
something or need to see an explanation
again they can just step backwards go
back and see that instruction again and
then go forward so it's a completely
linear way of stepping through a program
and understanding how it executes and
then finally it ties it back in the
lesson explains the side effect of the
semantics and then gives more examples
as they as they go forward then the last
thing I said that they're asked to
predict what will happen so here's an
example of somebody saying well what did
the zero greater than ten part of this
example do what will end up on the stack
over here this should be true or false
they look like true which was wrong and
it gave an explanation and they realized
why it was wrong and then chose false
and that was the resulting of that
operation right so very granular
explanation of exactly everything that's
happening as the program executes so
what was the effect of this part of this
was actually trying to build this in the
first place we had to completely react
detect the language stuck we had to
build a parser that would maintain
provenance of the origins of all of the
tokens and parts of the grammar so that
we could link that to runtime state we
had to facilitate reversibility and
embedded instruction in an execution
trace so if anybody knows anything about
how you build a compiler this is a
completely different architecture for
building a compiler to make this
instruction possible right we also had
to redesign the language grammar to
facilitate more granular explanations of
parts of the programming language as
well and the effect of it was when we
ran a four-hour controlled experiment to
have somebody have students go through
this we had about 40
cs1 students who hadn't ever learned the
programming language before and we
measured learning with this new
validated assessment of cs1 outcomes the
tutor led to 60% higher scores on this
test compared to the code Academy
JavaScript tutorial and did that in
about half the time as well so very
rapid learning in just a couple of hours
for all of the JavaScript language
semantics the most exciting thing is
that we in a small sample we almost also
saw an increase in their midterm scores
that train
for to Java which is what our cs1 course
is taught in so that was explicit
instruction of semantics this last one
I'll talk about is reminding the learner
to follow the semantics reminding that
the semantics exist and having them have
a strategy around using them so my
newest student Benjy che he started from
this premise that when learners have
really brittle knowledge of semantics
their strategy is often to just guess
what the semantics are and then they use
that to reason about how the program
will execute so he wanted to give them
an explicit strategy for reading
programs that prompted them to use their
knowledge of the semantics in their
reading of the code and that should
outperform guessing so the strategy was
really simple this is the strategy it
was understand what you're being asked
to do find where the program begins
executing execute each line according to
the rules of Java and then there's this
sub strategy from the syntax figure out
the rule follow the rules map the
side-effects of the rules and then find
the code for the next part that will
execute it's a really basic top level
strategy for how to read a program and
this is the result so they end up with
this program on a piece of paper
lots of annotations that follow that
strategy and then the effect of this as
predicted is pretty powerful so in just
15 minutes of practice of this strategy
the 12 students who learned the strategy
were more systematic than the 12 who
didn't they had 15% higher performance
on some tracing problems we gave them in
the lab almost a great point higher on
the midterm that they took about four
weeks later after this experiment and in
the experimental condition none of the
students failed the midterm where as 25%
of the control group participants did so
this really simple strategy of just 15
minutes of practice sort of transformed
their ability to read programs so this
synthesis here is when it comes to
reading code and understanding what
programs do requiring learners to
directly observe the operational
semantics of a programming language and
map them onto syntax can really promote
much better learning outcomes than we
can't otherwise now I'm not assuming
that they're going to infer these things
on their own
but explicitly instructing on them it's
very powerful this last half of this
last part of the talk is going to be
about writing problems we haven't made
as much progress on this I think it's a
harder problem but I want to talk about
a theory that we have an idea for how to
how to teach this more effectively and
so when we think about program writing
there's actually little work trying to
figure out what does it mean to know how
to write programs anyway what is that
skill what is what does that school
composed of most work kind of talks
about the differences between experts
and novices shows that novices are sort
of unsystematic and that they're
speculative and this is mostly
ineffective there are few papers that
show that the most effective developers
are better self regulators that they
regulate their problem-solving and and
that is related to more higher
productivity so here's what this concept
means it's basically a set of skills
that you probably all recognize in
yourselves as successful people explicit
planning skills explicit monitoring of
your process explicit monitoring of what
you understand and what you don't
understand reflection on your cognition
right metacognition self explanation of
the decisions you make why did you
decide this why did you not all of these
executive functions around better
problem solving or generally correlated
with lots of better learning outcomes
and better problem solving in lots of
disciplines the hypothesis is that this
is true in programming as well and in
fact when we look at sort of in practice
one of the studies that we've done for
my former students Paul Lee he
interviewed about 59 Microsoft senior
developers and almost 2000 in a survey
and he found that when developers
reported what made somebody a great
engineer self-regulating self-regulation
skills where one of the top three
attributes and what makes somebody a
great engineer so that skill seems to be
an intrinsic part of writing code
writing great software so my student
Dustin I took this work and started
theorizing about how is self-regulation
related to writing software in what way
does it actually help somebody write
code so he talked about programming is
involving sort of six
core activities interpreting the problem
they're solving searching for similar
problems that they might solve it
searching for solutions to those
problems evaluating those solutions
implementing them and then evaluating
the implementation and note that writing
code is is just this one bullet here
right everything else here is actually
about planning everything else here is
about trying to reflect on decisions
that she's made and so his theory was
that programming what it really requires
is a whole big repository of a whole
bunch of patterns of solutions to
problems and understanding of about the
mapping between problems and solutions
and then the key thing is that
self-regulation skills actually link all
of these activities they help you decide
when to switch from one to the next it
help you decide when it's time to
evaluate when it's time to try rewriting
something and so on and developing those
skills is actually the challenging part
of writing code so the first thing he
set out to do was find out if this was
was true and so he looked at sort of a
cognitive interview a think aloud study
with 37 novices that were in a couple of
interosseous courses and had them write
solutions to some programming problems
and he found that most novices get
engaged in some degree of
self-regulation but most of it was
infrequent or shallow or superficial in
some way they weren't very good at it
yet but when we looked at those who did
it well they were actually much more
highly correlated with fewer errors in
the programs that they wrote only when
they had sufficient prior knowledge
right if they if they had mastered the
concepts in what we were testing and
what problems they were solving those
self-regulation skills were really
powerful if they didn't have that
knowledge it didn't matter how good they
were self-regulating they still failed
so that was pretty consistent with the
theory that we had we had developed so
the big question is here can we actually
teach these self-regulation skills
because if we can then everybody can be
a better developer they can write
programs more effectively so what we
tried to do is we set up a two-week
summer camp with 48 high schoolers none
of them had at Overtoun any code before
we spent the first week teaching them
HTML CSS JavaScript and react and for
those who don't know what react is it's
not the easiest thing to learn it's a
pretty difficult a distraction
to wrap your mind around and so this was
a strong test right we were trying to
figure out how far can we get somebody
with no knowledge of programming to go
in two weeks so the treatment group
received a couple of things they learned
about Dustin eyes theory of programming
so they had explicit knowledge of how we
believed programming worked and what was
hard about it and then critically they
received this intervention and the
intervention was anytime one of the high
schoolers wanted help before we would
offer them help we would ask them to say
what activity are they doing what was
their strategy for performing that
activity and was their strategy working
and the purpose of that was to try to
foster these self-regulating skills to
help them reflect on their planning on
their comprehension on their strategies
and so on and so I mean the control
group we would just help them
immediately like you would a TA in a
class right so inserting this
self-regulating prompting in in this
protocol was the key part of developing
this this skill so here's the outcome
along four measures
there was great success so the
experimental group participants who got
that prompting accomplished more in that
last week of class so they completed not
only more of the requirements that we
had for the class but they also defined
the requirements of their own and
completed more of those their
self-efficacy was higher significantly
over the last course of that week these
are longitudinal results on the bottom
left the green bars there are all of the
self defined requirements that students
performed and so they came up with more
of their own requirements and if and
finished them then the control group did
and then lastly here I thought this was
one of the most powerful things is that
this trend here of of growth mindset it
actually declined in the control group
over time which is something that others
have reported in higher ed settings as
well that's really scary the idea that
learning to code in a certain way would
make you believe that you can't learn
things anymore that's a scary outcome of
a class we prevented that erosion
through these self-regulation prompting
interventions so these are these are
really exciting results that means not
only can we teach some of these skills
in a class and it can result in very
short time better outcomes from
learning perspective but that we can
actually help preserve some of these
beliefs about learning future things
that's really exciting so when we talk
about writing programs really the lesson
here is the teaching programming
self-regulation skills really promotes
important things like independence and
increased productivity and higher self
efficacy and these are key things that
really don't appear in most of the other
settings that we've seen people learn to
code in so a couple of things about
what's next and then I'll open up for
questions
one of the observations that Benji's
made in the lab is that a lot of our
prior work shows increases in learning
outcomes through a lot of these
interventions including some of the ones
that I just showed you but not really
mastery right most of the interventions
we've had learners don't a hundred
percent understand the programming
language we taught them they sort of
understand it more than they would have
without our intervention but they
haven't mastered it they can't give
can't take any program and read it
perfectly they can't write any solution
to any problems so how do we get to
mastery a lot of times human tutors can
get us there because they can provide
really rapid immediate personalized
feedback around a lot of the conceptions
that that learners are starting with but
we can't really scale that very well and
so Benji's been working on a tutor that
sort of provides an infinite amount of
personalized practice by leveraging a
lot of interesting new techniques from
program synthesis where what we're doing
is we're taking our model of what
somebody understands about a programming
language and synthesizing the exact
program that tackles whatever they don't
understand about that programming
programming language yet right and the
ability to actually create content like
that is something that human tutors can
do we're going to be able to do it at
scale with a lot of interesting new
approaches to kind of monitoring and
modeling people's knowledge so the goal
here is to try to have students master
cs1 content in about ten hours rather
than ten weeks and I think that that's
possible through better instruction and
better feedback another project that I'm
working on with one of my copia is
Thomas Litella at George Mason and my
student das and I is self-regulation as
we looked at is only really useful with
good strategies it doesn't matter if you
can decide you need to do something
different if you don't have
an idea of what that different thing is
and so we've been thinking about what
our strategies what our programming
strategies how do we describe them which
ones exist when are they effective or
ineffective and in what contexts how do
we help people learn them and execute
those strategies so in the same way that
other engineering disciplines have
engineering handbooks that kind of
catalog all of the ways you solve all of
the major problems and let's say bridge
building right or architecture we need
something like that and software
engineering to sort of catalog all of
the strategies that guide solving all of
the problems in software engineering and
if we can regularize that knowledge I
think we can accelerate how quickly
people can learn and master all of those
things about software engineering so
we're really building a new science of
programming strategies through that and
then lastly with my cards in CS and my
student Kyle fair we've been thinking a
lot about what it means to learn api's
what does it mean to know an API what is
that knowledge what are their
prerequisites for being able to use it
productively and robustly
and so we're building a new theory of
API knowledge is this combination of the
domain concepts embedded in the API the
the templates that drive productive use
of it and some of the underlying
semantics of how API is executed and
then the exciting thing is to try to
take a source code for an API and
automatically extract all of that
knowledge because in some sense API is
actually explicitly represent all of the
things that must be known about it in
their implementation so how much of it
can we extract and build and synthesize
instruction around automatically and so
here we're going for robust API learning
at scale so I think there's a lot of
exciting stuff in this field the history
here is that this is a field that's been
around for a while but really hasn't had
a lot of attention or resources there
are a lot of great faculty like myself
that have started to work in this space
from other fields like PL and software
engineering and HCI and I think it as
it's rapidly growing and the number of
doctoral students is growing it's time
to resource it and really make it work
because we have approximately 500
million people who want to learn this
and it with the status quo about 500
million of them are going to fail to
learn it so think
about how to resource it think about
hiring in this space I hope you'll join
us thanks it was like right and like the
other ones like what's more like you
know like traditional educational
interfaces I'm guessing like the
gamification has a class engage with all
those good things is there a reason why
like yeah there's there are particular
reasons I mean I think that one premise
that I start with in a lot of
educational technology design is that
all things to some extent are a game
it's just that they vary in how good of
games they are I would characterize
let's say the programming language tutor
that I showed is a very bad game right
it's game mechanics are kind of boring
there's not a lot of positive
reinforcement in the game and you really
need to bring a lot of motivation to it
to stay engaged and successfully and
learn all of that material in contrast
the Gidget game was designed to be an
engaging game that was the primary
design goal of it to get somebody
through it and to try to understand how
design was impacting engagement and then
led to learning right so really it was
just different design goals for those
two different environments that um that
led to that when I think about sort of
the design of pedagogy in general I mean
I think about my own courses as games
when I described syllabus to my students
I tell them the rules of the game i
frame the class as a game and I think
that's just a way of recognizing that
all of these rules around learning that
we construct all of these environments
we create to promote learning they are
all artificial right they're they're not
an authentic environment in which we're
producing authentic things and so
recognizing that and just making that
explicit I think can just be a powerful
way of engaging people initially yes
free time I was wondering as we're
talking in the leader part of the
talking towards the future of one of the
things to you one of the things that you
were talking about were strategies and
I'm wondering you know to me
it overlaps a lot with patterns and
design patterns and I feel like you know
one of the techniques that we have now
is just collecting those patterns and
also creating pattern languages and so
I'm wondering how do you see the
difference between patterns and
strategies and what are some exciting
things that you're thinking about it
will be beyond ways that we have of
collecting these or helping people learn
strategies that's a great question so
let me give an example of a strategy
that most of you who write code today
have probably used so what's a good
strategy for trying to find the best
design pattern the best code to write to
use an API well you start by first
trying to formulate what behavior you're
trying to implement then you translate
that behavior into some query to Google
and then Google does the work of trying
to find the right 10 Stack Overflow
articles for you and then you read all
of the Stack Overflow articles and then
you try to triangulate between all of
the facts and sort of fake news inside
of them and infer the actual truth from
those 10 so that you can actually write
the behavior that you want right that's
a strategy that's a process that you can
follow to arrive at some design solution
to leverage an API but we don't talk
about those strategies as explicit
things right we don't try to define them
write them down we don't try to teach
people any of these strategies and so
when they go off and try to solve a
problem in a class or they're in a
software company trying to implement or
architect something we just sort of
pretend that everybody's skill set is
that they can magically define their own
strategies and that they will be
efficient and productive because they
can all define them what I found as a
CTO and as a manager of several
engineers is that nobody had any of
these strategies they were all highly
ineffective at solving problems and that
when we would just share our strategies
with each other everybody became more
effective really fast the challenging
thing and I think this is the research
question is how do we represent them
right I just gave you some natural
language representation of an API usage
strategy is that sufficient for helping
somebody productively learn it and
execute it or do we need more robust
support and scaffolding for learning
those strategies those are some of the
open questions that we're we're dealing
with
what do you think is like the level of
game that comes from personalization
versus just having like a really good
teacher recorded like you can record a
really good teacher have a user board
for questions and that scales really big
really quick like what's the game from
personalization cuz I think like even in
normal classes if it's like a really big
class you don't get a lot of
personalized time yet students still
kind of learn to stop I mean you ask
friends you Google as long as the
teacher is really good you get like most
of the stuff yeah well so what you just
said that's where I'll pick up you asked
friends Google that's that's a learner
trying to get personalized feedback
right that's that's somebody going out
and seeking instruction from their peers
they're seeking validation of their
their concepts from other people that
might have similar expertise or slightly
greater expertise from them one way or
not or the other if learnings gonna
happen that that feedback and validation
of whether you've got something right or
wrong and if so how that has to come
from somewhere so when we teach a class
of a hundred thousand people or a
hundred people or just ten people
somebody's got to produce that for
learning to happen right
sometimes the lecture can contain that
because there's enough exploration of
right and wrong answers that somebody
can self validate those things sometimes
a Stack Overflow article that has ten
answers in it nine of which are wrong
helps you see that space and kind of
recognize whether you're understanding
what's right or wrong but in my view
sort of all of these boiled down to sort
of key requirements for deliberate
practice right that has to there has to
be feedback somewhere that responds to
your conceptions and if it doesn't
learning isn't gonna happen I think we
just need to recognize how that
manifests in the different learning
settings that we talk about right as a
manager when I was teaching my engineers
it was very direct sort of tutoring
based things in a massive online course
it's probably going to be all of this
sort of invisible study groups that
happen in pure interactions that happen
but it's happening one way or the other
yeah I want to push back a little on
this idea of being able to master
cs1 material yeah come out um I'll just
stipulate that maybe you can get people
to read programs effectively and
understand the semantics about what
we're trying to do in the cs1 it's got
people to be able to write programs at
the level they'll need to do in
subsequent courses and certainly yeah
the last assignment yeah and our course
takes more than ten hours even for the
best students so what does it mean how
could you master or how could you know
in ten hours whether people have the
ability to write a program that took
longer than your close elapsed time yeah
construct I mean I think you may be
defining mastery in a different way than
we do yeah it's a great question I think
there's three things that we can sort of
surface to reconcile that conflict one
is the ridiculous like provocative
number that I used so we'll put that
aside and just let that be what it is
right the second part of play I think is
that um we have ill-defined notions of
what a cs1 class is even for what is the
what is the capacity of that course to
promote learning and how far can
somebody go in it right I don't think
we've defined that in many ways we've
we've desperately searched even for one
cs1 class to have some well-defined
learning objectives but we just can't
find any way all the faculty we ask we
have never really written them down what
do we want somebody to know in the
closets not always that clear so I think
that there's varying notions of where
where we want learning to happen and
then the third thing at play there is
that my hypothesis around that small
number of hours or the orders of
magnitude number of smaller of hours is
that the ways that we teach these things
are so bad that there are big wins early
on right I just think that so much of
what we don't teach is so critical
actually learning this stuff that the
moment we teach it even if we teach it
poorly that we're going to get orders of
magnitude gains and then from then on
we're probably going
be incremental right so it's those big
wins that my lab is going after right
now where we're trying to really
understand what are the critical things
that are missing from pedagogy to get
those big wins and then you know I'll
let other people optimize and other
things but I really think we want to
reshape how it is that that we teach it
by trying to define what it is that
we're teaching thank you for laying out
strategies that will hopefully touch
more and more lives in the future what
has been in your experience in opinion
the biggest bottleneck and having that
happen has been research challenge or
funding or institutional bias can you
restate your question tell me more about
the strategies that you want to know
about well my question would be what is
so for example a lot of the machine
learning algorithms I used today were
invented a long time ago it's simply
with increasing computational power and
also increased amount of data
availability that you know able to use
them they're the bottleneck was those
two things and what here is the biggest
public in having these become more
mainstream yeah I think that in general
all of this knowledge about computing
whether it's really basic concepts like
some of the ones that I've talked about
all the way to advanced concepts like
machine learning when I see I sort of
see structural bottlenecks in in
research right so all surfacing a couple
that I think are important most people
think of computing education research as
sort of a backwater of both computer
science and education right and so who
wants to do a PhD in that who wants to
do research in that that's not something
where you're going to build a reputation
that's not something where you're going
to be able to sort of we have great
achievements right and so there's
actually a whole sort of under-resourced
part of investigation and scholarship in
that space that I think is holding back
a lot of this and then in terms of
actually disseminating it right this is
something that's true for almost all
academic disciplines when we make these
discoveries how do we actually get these
discoveries in the hands of people doing
learning and people doing teaching right
that's a big challenge as well so I've
had to also tackle things like I'm
sitting on the Washington state
governors Board for a case
twelve implementation for CS education
right and having to work through all of
the policy challenges and all of the
teacher training challenges to try to
just get some of these discoveries in
the hands of teachers is its own
challenging problem right and I think
that we have to rethink as academics
what our role is in doing some of that
dissemination because it's not going to
be a teacher going and seeking out a PDF
on the ACM digital library that
transforms their learning right we
actually have to bring it to them and
find the right representation for it too
and I think that's an equally important
part on top of our discoveries this last
comment so a lot of what you shared by
the way great talk great great work it's
needed because for the last thirty years
folks like the person sitting right next
to me has been saying a lot of these
things like why is programming difficult
syntax semantics pragmatics it's all
those things tied up you know not just
ROI but you know solloway and EE and
I've sort of written all that from you
know it's an educational literature and
so I think I want to hear your thoughts
on how to bring you know work in these
interdisciplinary spaces where a lot of
work is done in one discipline but it
probably is more meaningful to the
computer scientist and how so how do we
bring these disciplines closer together
and you don't have people in computer
science actually read that literature
from 30 35 years yeah
I've talked to a lot of your great
doctoral students this morning and some
of these issues came up around what does
it mean to be a member of a community a
scholarly community and I think that
that's actually at the heart of you know
what your question is because I don't
view my role as sort of just deepening
some literature in some domain-specific
education research community right part
of my role is actually to bring it to
other communities - my job is to
communicate these things to computer
scientists my job is to communicate them
to education researchers and if my
entire career ends up being a bridge
between those two communities and that's
the function that I play in that
that scholarly community I'm actually
okay with that I don't need to have you
know bigger roles or larger roles we all
have some role to play in our
disciplines and none of us are going to
completely reshape the disciplines on
our own right so for my students I
always try to help help them think
through what do they want their role to
be in the next phase of their career
what role do they want to play in their
community and and how can I position
them to get to that place and I think
that's something for everybody to think
about as they plan their studies so I
just wanted to call out one specific sub
problem of this really hard task you
described defining a program and some
people have to refer to this as like
abstract I mean there's this degree of
algorithmic thinking sorry but that sort
of abstract reasoning is hard because
you know we can't target it directly it
usually needs to be instantiated in some
sort of problem and I found that this is
often in the friends that I talk to you
the point of dropout is like you know my
brain just doesn't think that way I
can't learn to think that way and so we
can teach you know operational semantics
we can teach mouthing on the syntax but
one of the strategies that you've
discovered for really getting someone to
think algorithmically
yeah I'll start with an important
disclaimer which is I don't think most
of us understand much about that problem
at all I don't there's not a lot of
research on it there's not a lot of
literature talking about that in
particular in computing or in learning a
program I do think that the more basic
discoveries we have suggests that some
of the some of the assumptions that we
make about what knowledge will
generalize are just not true so let's
say you teach somebody recursion right
in Java there's a hope amongst computer
scientists that once they learn
recursion in Java that they will no
recursion it everywhere right that that
will just immediately transfer to all
possible settings in which recursion
applies that doesn't happen right and
most of what we've seen in learning
science in education shows that transfer
like that is really rare or never
happens at all and that if you want to
do it you actually have to build really
intentional bridges from one context to
another and so I think there are some
basic beliefs about learning amongst
computer science teachers and
and instructors that just are not true
they're just not not true with respect
to how we understand learning and but if
we take some of that prescriptive advice
like teach to teach
recursion in Java and then teach it in
12 other languages that might actually
be a really powerful strategy it's
exactly what my programming languages
teacher did I feel like I understand
recursion and at least 12 languages
because she chose 12 I could have
understood it in the 13 if she chose 13
right maybe I even understand it now in
all of them because I could generalize
across all of those different semantics
right
so even transferring some of our basic
understanding about learning to computer
science would probably result in better
learning in general
[Applause]
you